you want to know what's amazing so these
uh Arab world leaders never saw it
coming Twitter popped up in their
country and they said what does it
matter if people are posting where
they're going to breakfast and when
they're using the toilet and what
happened was Facebook and Twitter which
come on let's be real you know they have
back doors for the federal government
intelligence agencies
they were operating sock puppet accounts
to sew Discord in these nations this is
a fact we know that they did this they
create fake accounts they'll have 50
accounts run by one individual to create
the perception of popular opinion than
for the people who live in these
countries when they log into the app the
only thing they see is dissent they see
horrible videos of police brutality of
government atrocities they start getting
angry about it then they see everyone
Tweeting or posting on Facebook how
there's gonna be a big protest and
through the manipulation of the Mind
through social media they're able to
foment these protests